can you saw some time in life where you
had to give up something and what that
decision or action or how that decision
or action has impacted your life ever
since sure ever since I was a kid all I
ever wanted to do was become a
professional baseball player that was my
dream and I've wanted to all the way up
until it's a freshman year in college
but when I got into high school that's
when I discovered acting for the first
time and I fell in love with it and I
really had no intentions of quitting
baseball I was planning on doing both I
played Little League optimist ball so I
played all throughout high school and
freshman year in college had arrived and
I actually I was planning to do both
acting and baseball I took the
initiative to hunt down the coach of the
University of Miami baseball team I
found him in his office I said hey I
want to try out for the team he was like
all right here's tryouts so but I
realized that if I made that team I'm
available to audition I would be able to
be in the school play so I had to it was
that time when I had to make decision of
which
I just followed my instincts that shows
acting and how that's affected me I've
had a great time without
but I've never forgotten baseball sports
and I always wanted what it liked about
what would have happened where would
I've been and it's still in me to this
day I still play sports every other day
whether it's running or basketball or
tennis and I do consider actually
possibly pursuing baseball game joining
team or tendances and other sport
ethanol in love with in high school and
college
pursuing that as well so the impact is
is that I still think about it I've
never forgotten baseball
thinking about what what my life would
be like if I took that road
you